dr jack bright is a man known by many
names and whether that name is oh god no
or just jack if you've spent any amount
of time here on scp explained you've
surely at least heard of the good doctor
once or twice he's a high-ranking senior
staff member at psyc19 one of the
foundation's most notable facilities and
has served as a director and important
member of the foundation's upper ranks
for decades of course you wouldn't be
able to tell that by looking at him
because depending on the current
circumstances dr bright might not look a
day over 13 or 80 or 90 or he might just
be a chimpanzee this is because dr
bright in his younger days came into
contact with scp-963
a metal amulet that gives its wearer's
consciousness immortality when the
amulet is moved from one body to another
dr bright's consciousness moves with it
allowing him to occupy a variety of
bodies from animals to old ladies dr
bright has been them all heck bright's
body swapping abilities have even proven
themselves to be incredibly useful for
the foundation so the guy is able to get
some actual work done when he's not
goofing off in undercover operations dr
bright has been used to infiltrate areas
that the foundation would typically have
trouble reaching or when clandestine
operations are the best course of action
in the 2000 united states election dr
bright briefly occupied the body of
george bush in order for the foundation
to investigate political opponent al
gore's activities without suspicion but
that mess is a story for another day
today we're going to be taking a look at
a different side of dr jack bright one
that isn't so overt one that's lurking
behind the joking facade and silly
antics so commonly associated with
bright's identity this is scp explained
and we'd like to welcome you into the
complicated dramatic and ultimately
tragic world of the bright family
specifically the story of scp-590
your consciousness being immortal
certainly has its perks for one you
can't die on the other hand you can't
die we all know the old cliche about
immortality how your friends and loved
ones will grow old and die off while
you'll stay the same age how centuries
will start to feel like months how your
mind will eventually crumble under the
weight of countless years and
experiences because no man was made to
live this long but while it is cliche
for us it's reality for dr bright he's
painfully aware of how futile his
situation is and behind closed doors it
scares him dr bride struggles intensely
with existential depression and for good
reason too right now he might be fine
but in the relatively near future he'll
start experiencing that cycle of death
and rebirth of those around him and
himself and over time that cycle will
just keep repeating body after body
friend after friend tragedy after
tragedy in the long term dr bright knows
that his life cannot have a happy ending
it's most likely because of this biting
inevitable future that bright makes the
most of his time with those around him
in the foundation making himself known
as a charming goofy personality brimming
with quirks and zaniness the part of
bright that makes others laugh does so
because deep down bright needs something
to take his mind off his situation he
wants the same type of familiarity and
comfort that he brings to other people
but bryant's public-facing persona is
often torn to shreds in private on top
of being an undying soul bright has to
contend with an even more stressful
experience his family the bright family
is a colorful assortment of old blood
that has run the inner circle of the
anomalous world for generations there
are members of the bright family that
were there when the first administrator
signed the policy that created the scp
foundation members who serve time on the
overseer council and even those who
operate outside of the parameters of the
foundation dr bright is just one among
many other individuals of major
anomalous significance in his bloodline
and it's only fitting that every family
has its issues for the brights all
strong personalities who hold positions
of power in various places across the
anomalous world unity isn't exactly a
strong point in fact most of the family
isn't anywhere near each other each
member existing in their own bubble
working towards their own individual
goals that often do not align with the
rest of their kin but there are
occasions when the bright family all
come together to sneer at one another
from across the table and enjoy a nice
loving reunion though these meetings are
often called out of necessity and are
far and few between this gathering of
anomalous individuals is deemed
important enough by the foundation to
have its own designated security term
nicknamed code brown when a code brown
is issued it can only mean that the
brights are locked away in a room
convening arguing and scheming over
something of great importance to them
and the rest of the world should stay
out of their family business and when
jack bright got his latest call for a
family meeting from one of the family
members he was on speaking terms with he
could only think of just how bad of an
idea that was it had been quite some
time since bright saw the rest of his
family and he didn't particularly look
forward to when they would meet again in
the time since then bright had been
taking care of tj his younger brother
whose story is nearly as tragic as
jack's don't worry we'll get back to the
events of the family reunion soon enough
for now let's have a look at tj bright
tj was a product of the cruel brutal
attitude the early foundation took out
on the objects it contained needlessly
cold containment procedures that denied
basic needs for human anomalies
pointless tests that often resulted in
death or worse and a general lack of
regard for decency or ethics this
archaic era would come to an end upon
the formation of the ethics committee a
board formed in the upper ranks of the
foundation that would enforce a better
treatment of the objects contained by
the organization with severe
consequences for those that disobeyed
the new more human doctrine but in the
case of tj bright there was nothing the
committee could do
tj who had been given the designation of
scp-590 long ago was an ordinary person
who happened to have anomalous abilities
like countless others that the
foundation had dealt with before he
appeared to be permanently 16 years old
never aging or changing an appearance
once during his time in containment the
abilities in question that had caught
the attention of the foundation were
tj's inherent power to cure illness
physical mental injuries and wounds tj
could cure them all with just a touch of
his hand but at an unfortunate cost
whatever injury tj would cure it would
be mirrored onto his own body a giant
gaping wound could be healed by tj but
the after effects of such such as scar
tissue and any lasting side effects
would later appear on his own body
leaving the boy to feel the pain of
everyone he touched and healed the early
foundation needlessly exploited the
scp-590s abilities and tests and
procedures testing the limits of tj's
body and its abilities this of course
was carried out without the knowledge of
his brother dr bright who at the time
did not have enough pull or power within
the organization to save his brother he
could only watch and hope that one day
scp-5 could live a better life outside
of his cell as tj bright and not a
number on a placard to be experimented
with so casually the foundation's
experiments with tj sometimes involve
the use of scp-500
an all-curing panacea that would fully
heal as cp-590
and bring him back to full health a
state that would later be reverted when
the foundation started their experiments
with the boy once again tj had endured
immeasurable pain and as a result had
suffered a broken mental state over the
years as time went by and things within
the foundation had started to change
including jack wright's prominence he
worked as hard as he could to push
through bureaucratic red tape and work
out a solution that would leave tj in a
less torturous position and when the
time came it was jack bright who made
the call to have scp-590 cure a variety
of specific mental conditions that would
leave the boy in a dulled state unable
to fully comprehend the pain he endures
should the foundation ever have to
utilize tj's abilities again wright's
decision to do this to his brother was
questionable and a part of the doctor
regrets it to this day but at the time
it seemed like a more preferable option
than having scp-590 be fully aware of
what was happening to him unfortunately
the idea that tj's reduced mental
capacities would prevent him from
understanding what was occurring to him
was a misunderstanding and tj was still
more than capable of perceiving what was
happening to him and that was pain he
knew he was being hurt he knew he wasn't
loved and even though his mind was
unlike rights or those who experimented
with him he felt the same things they
did by the time of the reunion tj was
fully in the care of dr bright
eventually the modern foundation worked
out that it was doing the poor boy more
harm than good to keep him locked up in
a cell all day and bright who is now one
of the most notable and important
individuals in the foundation was able
to pull enough strings to get tj out of
confinement now he could truly rest
without worry that he would be exploited
and abused safe alongside his older
brother inside the meeting room all of
the famous figures of the bright family
while the ones that were alive at least
were there dr bright sat alongside tj
who occupied himself with a coloring
book and a set of crayons from across
the table was michael bright better
known as overseer 05-6 a former
foundation agent who operated under the
name of
cowboy 05-6 was a hardened individual
with a heavy interest in firearms and a
whole lot of luck on his side mikhail
and jack almost at the same time both
fired out remarks about how bad of an
idea they felt this reunion was the one
who called the reunion was their elder
sister claire bright whose aged body
felt notably out of place among the
collection of forever young brights
whether it was jax body hopping tj's
longevity or mikhail's use of scp-006
the overseer council's fountain of youth
to keep himself young for an extended
period of time also present was yorick
elroy jack wright's grandson as the
three of them discussed the state of
claire bright's apparent aging situation
yorick remarked that he thought she was
involved with that incident at site-23
this dr bright knew was referring to an
incident he'd rather forget where a
reality vendor contained by the
foundation attempted to give the bright
family himself mikhail and tj included a
happy ending where they would be cured
of their ailments and allowed to live
ordinary lives of course this was just
the product of a reality bend and the
fantasy quickly fell apart when the
brights realized what was going on jack
rather not dwelt on what could have been
across from york was foundation agent
sarah argent one of the youngest members
of the bright family who worked as an
overseer council's hand sinister a
special title granted to an assassin
used by the council to sort out messy
business for them the previous hand
sinister was none other than mikhail
bright whose pearl revolvers that came
with the position now belong to sarah
mikal was growing impatient and asking
how long it would take for the rest of
the family to show up the rest of the
family being the brights that weren't
involved in the foundation the powerful
individuals who had worked their way
into various groups of interest and
aspects of the anomalous world while
some directly opposed the foundation and
its mission and others were neutral they
were all brights which meant their
presence was necessary while the two
sides sometimes work together there was
always an air of bad blood and poor
trust between them dr bright in
particular was not looking forward to
the rest of this meeting the first to
arrive was an individual named nobody
who the foundation had a difficult time
keeping up with nobody was a title
granted from one person to the next who
each worked towards a greater plan that
only nobody knew the specific details of
leaving the foundation completely
unaware of the group's larger interests
nobody's voice was impossible to source
and her appearance was even harder to
pin down but she was there nobody
circled around the table remarking that
the other side of the family had sent
her first to make sure the foundation
brights were all abiding by the rules at
one point in time nobody did have
another name but in becoming the next
nobody she left her previous life behind
the next to arrive was claire lumanu ii
a human with electromagnetic abilities
whose motives were largely unknown when
she pulled back the chair to sit down
sparks flew in the air briefly startling
the rest of the room after that came
david blindman a gruff sunglass-wearing
member of the serpent's hand a group of
anomalous individuals who work to free
anomalies from the confinements of the
foundation who they call jailers blind
man was mikael's son and possessed the
anomalous ability to see into the future
he was the unofficial representative of
the unnumbered brood a subsection of the
bright family consisting of mikael's
illegitimate children from his wilder
days as a free-roaming foundation agent
and a constant reminder to the overseer
of his past naturally mikael was less
than pleased to see his son arrive and
then there was evelyn navon who
levitated into the room wearing a
traditional hijab and dress evelyn was
one of the original 13 founding members
of the scp foundation and matriarch of
most of the bright family unfortunately
evelyn was kicked off the council for
reasons unknown the rumor has it that it
had something to do with her terrible
experiments as a genius geneticist
creating monsters by splicing the dna of
the ordinary and the anomalous she sold
her work to groups of interests such as
dr wondertainment or prometheus labs who
benefited from having such fine test
subjects to work with her current
activities are largely unknown but as
the rest of the family knew they
couldn't be anything good the final
member of the bright family to enter was
the only one who was trusted by all of
them and was a man of many many names
who was most commonly referred to as
tamlin tamlin was a mysterious
individual who existed for centuries far
longer than any other member of the
family he had something to do with time
but no one was quite sure of what it was
that he did but they all knew that he
was important and that he was the only
one who attempted to keep peace and
balance between the various factions of
the family tamlin took a mental count of
the room realizing that everyone was
present and addressed them all ready to
explain why they were there collectively
the family came to realize that the one
who called the meeting claire bright was
not there tamlin solely explained that
she had passed away and he had called
the family together in her steed to
present a videotape containing her dying
wish the tape was concocted through
claire and tamlin's time shenanigans and
featured a recording of claire who
through tamlin's abilities to travel
through and control time was able to
respond and interact with the members of
the family in the room as morbid as dr
bright felt this was he would make sure
to treasure this final interaction with
his sister claire's recording contained
her will and with tamlin's help she
distributed gifts to the other members
of the family final remembrances she had
collected from across the anomalous
world for them to cherish an egg with a
universe inside of it for evelyn the
literal sword of damocles to hang over
mikael's head jack bright's first ever
bottle of whiskey that he made so many
years before documents she entrusted to
her daughter claire ii when it came time
for tj's gift however the boy suddenly
grew serious and declined it the
recording of claire understood and
stated that if he didn't want it then
she would instead have tamlin give it to
someone who needed it dr bright could
only wonder what it was that she had
planned to give tj but it seemed like
the boy's selfless nature had won again
and he was unable to accept it after the
gifts had been distributed the tape cut
out tamlin stated that this was all that
claire had recorded and that she wanted
her death to bring the family together
once again to remind them all that they
were family claire's sincerity had
brought the room to silence each member
of the family engaged in deep thought as
tamlin gave parting remarks one by one
each member left mikael was embarrassed
by the ordeal immediately trying to
revert back to his overseer mindset but
he couldn't claire's loss was already
affecting him in the end there was only
tamlin who left a single blue rose on
top of the vcr player that contained
claire's recording in remembrance of
someone he felt almost understood him as
dr bright left the meeting he still felt
conflicted about his family but at the
very least he felt there was progress
being made after all they had all been
in the same room for more than 10
minutes without trying to kill one
another he glanced at the boy at his
side wondering if he made the right
decision all those years ago while that
much and most of his job with the
foundation was uncertain he knew one
thing for a fact he had to protect tj
now go check out scp immortal dr bright
explained and
scp-963 what would you do if you were
immortal like dr jack bright for more of
the wacky world of jack bright